[Music]
hello everyone uh I'm uh Professor jagat
rajaka from nyang Technological
University Singapore uh I'm attached to
the computer science and engineering
department and my uh research is uh
mainly application to uh Computing
algorithm for uh uh biological data and
uh neuroimaging data so today I'm going
to talk about explainable Ai and its
application to uh drug Discovery and
Neuro
Imaging uh now the today's AI is mainly
done by Deep neural networks so usually
neural networks are considered as
blackbox because they don't tell
how the predictions are made uh how the
object detections are made so they are
considered as black box but recently
there's an interesting to unravel this
black box and giving some explanation to
the process of uh prediction or process
of object detection or regression uh
problems that are performed by neural
networks now this this has a lot of
advantages because uh this uh will build
trust with the users because then users
know why we are getting this kind of uh
uh prediction or this kind of results
from the AI methods and also uh as a
designers we will also get insight into
how our model can be improved
further uh and
also uh uh we will know the uh the
modeling the input data or input uh data
are processed or created uh by U uh
explaining our models of
predictions so this is the the overview
of my presentation I'll give an
introduction to explainable AI or
xai uh and uh I'll I'll introduce to you
to the methods of xai uh that taxonomy
and then we will focus on one method
which is called the saliency back
propagation methods and uh thereafter I
will explain uh two applications one for
drug mechanism
prediction uh and second one for
neuroimaging so this is uh how uh a
neural network uh or AI method works so
you have some input in this case a brain
image so you have this black box or the
Deep neural network and it will give you
a prediction for example by looking at
this image it could be MRI a CT whether
this person is healthy or not that is
what we are predicting using the AI
technology or the neural networks but uh
so we can predict whether this person
has a diseas is or not but uh the method
the neural network does not tell how it
comes about this output this uh outcome
so that is what explainable AI is going
to do it will take this prediction and
that method will explain how the
outcome uh uh resulted uh from this
neural network for example it will find
the
regions that are different different
between healthy and unhealthy patients
okay so in in order the here it we get
these regions as the regions that are
different from the patients and healthy
controls so these are called biomarkers
so sometimes this forward process of
prediction is called encoding so we are
we are what we are trying to do is
decoding the model to find out which
inputs are most important this is one of
the uh objective which inputs are
actually creating the
prediction so these are actually uh
simple classification of xai
methods uh they can be divided broadly
divided into two categories input based
and activation based the input based
basically trying to identify which
inputs are the most important uh inputs
and how they are contributing to the
output results and the activation based
methods basically looking at the nodes
activations and try to interpret the
activations by looking at the maximum
activated
nodes okay so uh we are focusing on the
input base methods uh the back
propagation methods uh they are the
Imports of the nodes the output nodes is
the most important node so that saliency
or the importance will be fed back using
back
propagation to the input so while you
are doing the back propagation it will
give it will find the sances of all the
nodes from output nodes to input nodes
okay and uh so there are two ways two
kinds of back propagation methods first
one is the uh uh salien back propagation
methods that is what we are going to use
today and the other one is the Class
Activation Maps Okay and perturbation
means you are giving some perturbation
to the input uh input individually and
find out which input is causing the
output to change most so that you can
identify which inputs are most Salient
or the key inputs right so these are the
CATE category a broad classification of
xai methods but today we are focusing on
the saliency back propagation methods
that's what we are going to use for the
applications so saliency propagation
method uh means that uh we know the
importance of the output node because
that gives output so there's a using
back propagation we we back propagate
that saliency of the node to the
previous layer and from that layer we
propagate to the previous layer and we
going back to the input layer so while
we are moving to the input layer we we
are giving some saliency or the
importance of that node for the
contribution to the output so that we F
we will find which nodes are actually
creating this uh output so that we can
give some
explanation okay so there are uh
different methods slightly different
methods uh coming on uh under saleny
propagation method in integrated
gradients layerwise relevancy back
propagation or lrp on deep lift U and
here your right hand side you will see
uh the uh equations the back propagation
equations how the gradients are S stand
for
saliency and uh the San gradients are
calculated and that propagation from the
output to the input layer right uh but
I'm not going to go through all these
equations but uh they differ slightly
different with the back uh the gradient
equations that they are going they are
using to uh propagate the saliency to
the layer
before so this is what we are going to
use today uh to our
applications so these are uh some of the
applications of XI xai Technologies uh
Healthcare
by U Healthcare by applying xcii
techniques explaining the outputs uh you
can Enlighten the disease
mechanisms uh by revealing the uh
decision making process uh and also you
can build the trust because when you
give some explanation to your output you
can build the trust with the uh patients
okay uh and also the in insurance for
example uh uh by giving explanation how
uh that that prediction is made by uh
the AI technology you can build the
trust uh
transparency and auditability of the uh
Insurance in the insurance industry and
also in the
manufacturing um uh by making um uh uh
you now you can use AI Technologies to
diagnose some mechanical for in
manufacturing industry and fixing in IND
equipment failure but by making this
process
explainable uh so you can create the
awareness between the human and the uh
machines or The Operators and the
machines so that they know how to use
these machines better and also auton
autonomous vehicle uh you know uh AI
methods are driving these autonomous
vehicles so uh by uh providing some uh
explanation to the methods uh we can
identify what causes accidents or what
how human can intervene to avoid these
things so those things uh can be sorted
out by using explanatory methods of
AI so these are some of the
applications but today I'm going to do
uh two applications that uh we have
worked on one is drug mechanism
prediction so drug means a chemical
molecule right usually uh uh small
molecule so it has a chemical structure
right it has a chemical structure and
this chemical structure is given to your
body and that will interact with some
molecules some proteins uh uh some G
some uh proteins uh which are created by
certain genes so so the drug mechanism
means how this molecule or the drug
interact with the biological Mo
molecules in our body the proteins for
example okay how the reaction so this
reaction uh can be predicted uh
reactions can be identified by using
explanatory uh uh
AI so this is uh how AI technique is uh
using for drug uh drug uh finding Noble
drugs for example okay so you a a drug
is a a chemical compound a small
chemical compound so uh this is the
molecular structure the structure is
given by the uh you know chemical
structure and then genes and proteins uh
are given by the genomic uh uh multi
multiomic data so you can use genomics
data to measure uh you know genomic
expressions or mutations of the genes
and then gene expression data proteomics
data and those data can be computed so
these uh data the molecules in the body
proteins uh or RNA such molecules will
interact with the uh interact with a
drug molecule and and and then they make
a reaction in the body so that it can
fight the virus or the bacteria so what
we are trying to do is we are trying to
decode this process and identify how
which functional units of
this drug compound is interacted which
proteins or which genes because as you
know the genes are converted into
proteins uh by translation and uh
transcription and translation process so
basically we can find which genes are
actually interact with this this uh are
affected by this drug and if you know
how they are interacting then we can
come up with noal drugs noal drugs uh to
certain uh diseases so this is the
process that uh we have worked on uh we
have worked on first the drug response
prediction and uh using AI technology
neural networks and then by using back
propagation uh the sany back propagation
we have identify which genes are
reacting with this drug molecule and
which part of the uh molecule or which
functional of the molecule are
interacting with the uh genes uh so we
have found out so using this these
findings we can create new drugs so this
is the work that we are working uh in my
lab so I'm going to explain uh some part
of it where how we use saliency back
propagation method to give uh to find
the drug interacting
mechanisms all right so this is a a
neural network that we have used to
predict drug response from multiomic
data so multiomic data means U trans
cryptomic data which measure Gene
Expressions so using microarrays or RNs
data we can calculate the expressions of
thousands of genes and then uh copy
number variation data using uh genomic
data we can find the copy number
variation throughout the uh throughout
the genome and then mutation data you
can col RP pa uh means uh protein
expression data and the metabolix data
so this data can be gathered today
without much cost and the cost is
decreasing so we believe in future uh
with this uh you can collect this
multiomic data to discover uh detect
diseases and uh and U and identify
biological functions this multiomic data
can be used for example we have used U
uh cell line data uh and expression data
their protein Expressions metabolic data
to predict how the cell react to
different drugs so we have used this AI
deep neural network to predict the drug
response so what we have is a input
layer and this an embedding layer and
then we have a fully connected layer and
then we have a uh a tension layer and an
output layer concatenation layer and the
output layer so there are the sances are
measured by the attention layer with the
attention layer it will allocate
weights uh depending on their importance
for the drug prediction that means which
uh of which omix data are actually
important for drug
prediction okay so here we have done
this experiment so you can see this is
the decoding data on your right hand
side uh so you can see uh in this uh
color map you can see uh gene
mutations and protein expression rppa
data are actually uh more important in
the predictions so other data are not uh
really important in predicting the drug
response so you can see actually these
drugs are actually uh affect uh uh
dealing with the mutations of the genome
as well as some protein
expressions are affected by this this uh
these drugs so that is how we explain uh
why uh we we are able to predict drug
response and which of the omix data are
contributing this to this
prediction uh this is another uh uh
neural network we call it X
GDP uh basically we have used uh uh drug
chemical data so it's like a graph
actually the if you look at the chemical
structure of the drugs it's it's like it
has a graphical structure so we have
used the graph neural network or GNN uh
to process this uh uh chemical structure
of the drugs and also uh we we have used
Gene expressions in this one so we are
trying to uh uh predict uh the drug
using both gene expression data and the
chemical structure of the drug so uh by
processing gene expression with the CNN
and chemical structure of the drug with
the GNN we are able to predict the drug
response so here uh on the table you
will see the accuracies uh of uh our uh
technology so using different uh graph
neural networks uh and we find the Gat
uh graph attention networks uh actually
works uh well in this one so um so now
our we want to identify which genes are
affected by uh this drug or controlled
by this drug and which U uh chemical
features of the drug is actually
interact with these genes so what we do
is now we go from the output layer to
the input layer by propagating the
saliency back propagation methods so
this uh the top uh you can see the
chemical structure of the drugs so uh
the color coded it will tell you which
part of the drug chemical structure is
actually reacting with the gene
expression data so red means those
regions are the most important regions
that are interacting with the genes
genes and we have color coded the genes
in the two bars actually these vertical
axis are all Gene Gene names so you can
see certain genes the red genes are the
yellow the color by is high that means
those are the genes actually uh affected
by these drugs genes uh those are
affected by this so we can give some
explanations not 100% explanation but
certain kind of explanation to this drug
prediction how uh this drug chemicals
and genes are interacting with each
other and how they contribute to uh uh
drug prediction which genes are actually
acting with the drugs okay or which
proteins genes mean Pro produce proteins
so which proteins are actually
interacting with this chemical structure
and which chemical structure are most
important for this so now we are working
on actually by using this finding to
create new drug new drugs uh uh uh drug
candidates so we have used some
generative AI to generate uh new drugs
using the interactions that we find from
by decoding the drug response prediction
I'm not going to go into this uh this is
something that we are currently working
on so our next application is a
functional MRI uh uh data or functional
uh neuroimaging how the xci uh can um uh
can help us to identify
biomarkers basically um the I mean we we
can have the connector data the
functional uh MRI uh we derive the
functional connector of the brain and
from DTI diffusion tens Imaging data we
can uh we can generate the uh structural
connector that means the brain networks
uh in the macroscopic scale and by
encoding uh we can predict certain
things whether this person has a disease
or not and then a disease subtype the
classification of the task the person is
doing and treatment response cognitive
measures we can predict by encoding the
uh Imaging data by decoding that means
we are going the
backward by explaining the important
inputs we can find the biomarkers that
means which part of the brain is
actually different from for example
different from healthy patients and P P
healthy controls and patients so we can
intervene those regions by using a drug
or some mechanism those regions to treat
this uh persons so basically when you do
decoding uh we can find
biomarkers uh and also we can find the
individual variability of the
biomarkers so uh this process I will
explain how uh neuroimaging is uh used
uh in this expression we we are dealing
with functional MRI data the functional
MRI will tell you which regions are
activated uh during a particular task
but uh in this case we are using resting
state data of uh subjects so even the
resting States some regions are
activating in the resting state right so
uh we build a network uh we divide the
region into certain um using a certain
Atlas we divide it into regions and then
uh we build a network by connecting the
regions so basically this network is
represented by a
matrix that means the rows are actually
brain regions and the columns are of the
same regions so in the in this
metrics uh so uh one element
represent how how strong is the
connection between one region and the
other regions so it's color coded here
the metrix is color coded this is called
the connectivity Matrix and this network
is called the functional connector uh so
connectivity Matrix so this is the
Matrix that we are going to use for as
the input to our AI technique or deep
neural networks so by uh processing this
deep neural network say if you process
healthy healthy subject and uh uh
patients if you train this neural
network using both kinds of uh subjects
uh when after training when a new um
image is given we can find the connector
connectivity metrix from of that subject
and we can use the neural network to
predict whether this person has disease
or not right so we can use the uh uh
saliency back propagation methods from
the output to the input layer uh output
to the input layer uh so that we can uh
find out uh which regions or which
connections are most important you know
the rightmost diagram the the connec
metrix now we have color coded that
means the yellow regions as the most uh
uh mostly important connections that
create this differentiation between
patients and healthy subjects so in
other words you can use these regions or
connections as biomarkers to intervene
and uh and treat this patients okay so
the biomarkers means we are trying to
find out from the the blue Matrix that's
the resting state connectivity Matrix
which uh which connectiv connectivities
are different from the patients and the
uh and the and the healthy subjects so
those are called biomarkers uh and uh
those connections uh can be uh could be
useful for treating these uh
patients so this is a network that we
have used we call it a lean basically uh
it's a fith forward neural network uh we
give the connectivity metrix as the
input and the output will be uh whether
it's a healthy subject or disas subjects
so how we did that this model we built
basically uh we we we did the forward
pass by training this neural network and
then we use saliency back propagations
so once we know the sancy back
propagation we know in the neural
network which nodes are the most
important nodes so what we did was we be
shed or we prune all these irrelevant
nodes or the nodes which are salien low
San so we make a very small neural
network by pruning the irrelevant nodes
of this so we we named this network lean
and we published this uh year ago this
network uh so using this network since
we found out the important uh only we we
keep kept only the important nodes of
the network we got a very simple
networks as well as we could interpret
the inputs because the only the uh
remaining inputs are the most salience
one for this prediction so we have done
this for using public domain data of
different diseases for example uh uh the
left hand side is the using
ad uh subject and U helthy subject and
ad uh Alzheimer's disease patients uh
biomarkers so this uh in the in this
color map the yellow means or white
means those are the most important
connections uh that were different from
uh Alzheimer disease patients and the
healthy subjects so these are the bio
markers on the right hand side actually
major depression uh depressive disorder
the patients and healthy patients we
have compared and these are the
biomarkers that we identify using the
previous uh network uh lean uh that are
different from uh this and we have
actually look at the literature at the
literature supports our findings uh that
actually these connections are actually
uh affected in Alzheimer uh or the right
hand side uh actually the major
depressive disorder actually these
connections are uh found earlier to be
uh uh uh having uh issues confounded uh
in these
diseases and another technique another
neural network that we have developed is
called shred because this neuroimaging
data are very rare so we have gathered
uh this uh Imaging data from different
different databases but when you gather
uh data from different different
databases the subjects age gender
demographic data are different so we
have to harmonize this data before we uh
before
we uh com harmonize to before we use uh
diff data from different different uh uh
sites to uh use uh for prediction so we
we developed a network which is called a
shred uh this uh this is the network
diagram you can see on the right hand
side um it's basically it's a encoder
decoder and classifier architecture and
we use the uh linear mixer model to
pre-process the data and uh and do this
for the prediction so uh by using this
approach approach we were able to U uh
find site specific that means now say if
you get data from Singapore and we get
some data from
USA what are the biomarkers that are
invariant because the Caucasian
population and Asian population we can
see which biomarkers are invariant using
because we in our model uh using shred
we we were able to combine data from
multiple sites so we what the biomarkers
we get is from the site in variant
biomarkers but if you train the network
with only USA Data so that those
biomarkers are uh related to Caucasian
population so uh from the right hand
side um uh we use Simple deep neural
network uh that will give very spice spe
site specific biomark markers but on the
right hand side we use the shred Network
which will give site invariant
biomarkers uh we develop another uh
neural network which is called the split
so this neural network can identify sub
types of uh diseases for example we use
the adne data set to find the subtype of
um Alzheimer's disease because it's very
heterogeneous the the ad patients are
not very uniform uh they have different
uh phenotypes uh and genotypes uh so we
want to identify the sub bio subtypes
all right so we build this neural
network which we call split so basically
we have few uh graph convolution neural
network layers and once we get into a uh
upper layer we get a representations of
the input data those are the
connectivity matric
and at a higher layer we classify uh the
truster these activations so these
clusters corresponding to uh different
subtypes of uh subjects right subtype of
subject so um um so we we uh we we did
uh we did and uh we we found that there
are four subtypes of AD and these ad
subtypes we had the snip data also
uh single nucleotide Mo polymorphism
data uh uh so we could map uh which
Snips are corresponding to which uh
subtype so we could find the
biomarkers corresponding to different
subtypes so the four subtypes these are
the biomarkers corresponding to the four
subtypes so with this uh I have come to
the end of uh uh my present presentation
uh in summary um I introduce you to what
explanatory uh AI means what are the
techniques and then I explained the
saliency back propagation method where
the saliencies are back propagated from
the uh uh output to the input and then I
showed how the drug Target interactions
are predicted uh by saliency back
propagation of uh s uh using saleny
propagation we feedback the sanes of the
nodes uh predicting the drug uh of the
neural network predicting the drug
response backward and find out the genes
uh which are interacting with particular
uh uh chemical features so what we did
was we had both gene expression data and
the chemical structure data
and we uh do a graph neural networks and
convolution neural network combination
to predict the drug response and then we
fed back um uh we fed back um uh to find
out which drug uh functional units are
interacting and which genes are affected
by this drug and thereafter I explain an
application to uh functional
Imaging where we use uh connector
matrices functional connector matrices
from resting state fmri data and that
connector was the input the neural
network and we we use that to detect the
uh different diseases from uh resting
state uh connectum data and be fed back
using San back propagation to find out
biomarkers which connection are actually
different in these diseases and the
healthy patients which can be used to uh
for in
interventions uh in
future uh but this uh our this
explanatory uh uh variables have to use
with some care uh because um uh because
there are some limitations of deep
neural networks uh in uh in um uh in in
building deep neural networks and so
on all right so that's the end of my
presentation thank you for your
attention